hello this is jim porter coming to you
from seattle washington
i'm here to present my experience with
robotic
retroperitoneal particularly for the
treatment of renal cell carcinoma
this presentation is part of the lab
roots cancer research
and oncology virtual event
so let me begin by
welcoming you to this event and i hope
you're able to gain some
valuable information about the treatment
of renal cell carcinoma
so we're going to talk a little bit
about
why partial nephrectomy is performed for
the treatment
of renal cell cancer and then why the
retroperitoneal approach
specifically using robotic surgery
and then going to end with some case
presentations to show you how this
technology is used
these are my disclosures as you can see
so a little bit about myself i did my
residency
in urology at the university of
washington and then went on to do a
fellowship
in laparoscopic surgery in germany and
then i was on faculty at the university
of washington
until 2005 where i
started doing laparoscopy and robotic
surgery and was the head of
laproscoming robotics there in 2005 i
moved to swedish medical center in
seattle
and since that time have performed over
4 000 robotic procedures
many prostatectomies and as well as many
nephrectomy procedures
i also teach i have a fellowship in
robotic surgery
and i'm currently training my 18th
fellow i'm also the director of robotic
surgery for the providence st joseph
health system
uh and uh this is a health care system
in the western u.s where
we have a very large uh group of uh
robotic surgeons
and we are really trying to perform
state-of-the-art surgery throughout our
system
so a little bit about partial
nephrectomy versus radical nephrectomy
so what is what is a partial nephrectomy
when there is a mass in the kidney uh
there's
two options to remove this tumor you
could remove the entire kidney
to remove the tumor or you can remove
just the tumor and leave the remainder
of the kidney behind
the other term for partial refectomy is
called nephrons bearing surgery because
you're sparing nephrons in the kidney
partial nephrectomy has become
more and more common because many of the
masses we're finding
now are found incidentally and they're
quite small
so because these masses are smaller
there's a higher chance that they are
benign in fact in some studies
20 to 30 percent of mass is less than
four centimeters uh can be benign so
it's quite uh
unfortunate if you take out a a entire
kidney for a benign mass so now
partial nephrectomy is a better option
in those smaller masses
another concern was that if you take out
the mass is there an increased risk of
cancer
coming back and it turns out partial
effectively appears to be equivalent to
radical nephrectomy
with regard to cancer recurrence so we
don't lose anything with regard to
cancer control by performing partial
nephrectomy
and probably most importantly um the
major benefit of
partial nephrectomy is that you maintain
more kidney tissue later into life
and it turns out there's significant
advantage in doing so
this is actually a study from the new
england journal medicine published by
alan go in 2004 which showed a
relationship between
the amount of preserved kidney tissue
and the number of cardiovascular events
so the correlation is that
the lower your egfr or the lower
of you the lower your overall kidney
function
the greater chance you have of having
cardiovascular events
so there is a relationship between
having more kidney tissue and improved
survival
particularly historically was was
performed open this is how it started
but with as many procedures now
minimally invasive surgery has become a
part of the surgical treatment
and both laparoscopic and robotic
approaches have been used for partial
nephrectomy
open surgery is really the standard uh
and
one of the big benefits of open surgery
is you can cool the kidney and this is
important because
in order to remove the tumor the kidney
blood flow is temporarily clamped and
when the kidney is cooled
it doesn't suffer the same damage when
there's no blood flow as opposed to if
it was
left at normal body temperature
there also appears to be a benefit
in that you can
mobilize the kidney more thoroughly than
you can with say a minimally invasive
approach
and so for many years open partial
effectiveness standard
the downside of open surgery as we've
seen with in many other procedures is
that the patient
pays a higher price for the surgery they
have a larger incision
and more pain and longer recovery
and so here's an example of an open
incision made for a nephrectomy
and you can see this is an incision
that's going to take a long time for
healing
laparoscopic partial affecting was the
first attempt to perform partial
nephrectomy using mineral invasive
technique
and this was performed uh using small
incisions in the abdominal cavity
and the controlling of blood flow with
either a large clamp as you see here
or what are called bulldog clamps which
are smaller clamps
once the tumor is removed then the
defect where the tumor
was located is closed so here's the
difference between
an open incision on the left
through the ribs and the smaller
incisions
for a laparoscopic partial refrectomy
and so these smaller incisions even
though they are incisions they tend to
heal faster
and patients tend to have less pain and
use fewer narcotics than they would with
an open procedure
the problem with laparoscopic partial
effect means it's very challenging to
perform
as i mentioned when there is the tumor
removed there's a defect in the kidney
that needs to be sutured
and suturing laparoscopically is very
challenging and requires a very
high level of expertise
and so therefore this was only really
performed at centers with significant
experience in laparoscopic surgery
the other uh issue around laparoscopic
surgery
is that it's sometimes difficult to
do this procedure efficiently and this
because the suturing takes longer
it means the kidney is clamped for a
longer period of time and that can
impact how the kidney functions
after the surgery so
the question was asked by many is could
we make laparoscopic
uh nephrectomy less challenging and
still
allow the benefit of smaller incisions
and minimally invasive surgery for our
patient
and as is very common now uh the davinci
surgical system which is a robotic
system
has been developed has evolved into
a multi-armed robot where a surgeon
actually sits at a console
um and is not at the bedside but looks
into a console
uh and the movements of the surgeon uh
hands are transferred uh via the robotic
controllers to the inside of the body
and what the
robotic instruments allow is first of
all
the robotic camera is a true 3d camera
so it's stereoscopic it gives you depth
it gives you better visibility and it's
a magnified view 10 to 15 times
the instruments that uh are used with
robotic surgery also have more degrees
of freedom meaning that they can move
um in more sp they can move
uh in space and not have not be
restricted by
the port that they're being placed
through so there's a wristed
benefit of these instruments which
allows the surgeon to perform
more complex maneuvers so here's what it
looks like the surgeon's over
looking in the console and the robots at
the bedside with the bedside assistance
into the patient so we started our
experience with robotic partial
forecasting in march 2006
and we um did this with both the
transparent meal and the retroperitoneal
approaches and let me explain
the difference retroperitone transparent
needle approaches involves placing the
ports
through the in the abdominal cavity
in the space where the intestines and
the other organs
are commonly located so this is a much
larger space
and the space is created by putting
carbon dioxide in the abdomen
and the ports for in for example
here are placed through the abdominal
wall into the transparent nail space
the retroperitoneal approach involves
placing the ports
in a space behind the
peritoneal cavity and by doing so you're
actually in the space
directly where the kidney is located and
so it gives you direct access to the
kidney
it also allows you to avoid the
intestines which means you're not
manipulating the intestines
so there's less risk of injury to the
intestines and also because you're not
manipulating the intestines they tend to
wake up sooner
and patients tend to eat faster and have
less
gastrointestinal complications from the
operation
our experience with laparoscopic partial
nephrectomy using both the transparent
and retroperitone approach
dated back several years and when we
started doing
retroperion surgery it was
laparoscopically we found with the
laparoscopic retroperitoneal approach
that patients
had quicker return to bowel function
they were in the hospital for a shorter
period of time
versus the transparent new approach and
their the operative time was shorter
so we felt that the retroperitoneal
approach offered several advantages
and the approach whether you perform
retroperitoneal or transparent needle
should be based on tumor location so
here's an example of a tumor located
on the back of the kidney now if this
procedure if this tumor was to be
removed using a transplanting approach
which by the way is the more common
approach this is where most
laparoscopic and robotic procedures
begin is via the
transparent neural approach if you were
to do this transparent nearly
you would be approaching the kidney
actually on the opposite side of where
the tumor is which means you would have
to
completely mobilize the kidney would
have to flip it to get access to this
tumor
and that would require more work more
time in the operating room
with the retroperitoneal approach your
access is directly on the back of the
kidney
and so this tumor would not have to be
moved this kidney would not have to be
moved and the tumor
would be in your face which would be a
bit of benefit
and would and the procedure would go
faster here's another tumor on the right
side here we see a tumor within the
center of the kidney the question is
would we do this retroperitoneally
no not necessarily we would actually
probably do this tumor
via the transparent needle approach
because this again would allow us to
have direct access to this tumor and
that would be more efficient and allow
us to get to the tumor
in a timely fashion so we base our
approach
trans versus retroperitoneal on tumor
location
so for uh medial and anterior tumors we
do the transparent nail approach
for posterior lateral tumors we do the
retroperitoneal approach
and we find these approaches are
complementary it's not that you do only
one approach
so i don't do all retro i don't do all
trans i do
the approach that's going to benefit the
access to the tumor and allow my
patients to have a shorter operative
time
so while this is good for posterior
lateral tumors they're also the benefit
for using the retroperitoneal technique
for patients who've had previous
abdominal surgery
when someone has had previous abdominal
surgery there's lots of scarring and
adhesions
and you can avoid all that by going
through the
right through the retroperiodic space so
here's an example of a patient who's had
a total colectomy
so we would anticipate a lot of scarring
and adhesions in the transparent space
you can avoid all that by going
retroperitoneally behind
the peritoneal cavity and avoiding the
scarring and adhesions
another group that really but does
benefit from the retroperiod approach
is the obese patient and we actually
find that the patients
who are obese carry most of their weight
in the front of the abdomen so here's a
patient here
with a bmi of 54 you can see they carry
most of the fat in front where you would
have to go through a much larger panus
to get to the
transcription of space retroperitoneally
there's less tissue to go through to get
into the space
here's an example of another patient we
did retroperitoneally
um again avoiding his previous scar and
the large abdominal
um cavity
so the retropyrin approach offers direct
access to the kidney and hilum
you don't need to mobilize the
intestines it's good to avoid previous
abdominal surgery
and you don't need to rotate the kidney
but there are some disadvantages
the retroperitoneal space compared to
the transparent space is a smaller
working space
the landmarks that are seen normally
from a transparent approach like the
liver and the spleen
and the colon are not there so the
landmarks are not familiar but there are
landmarks
uh that you will allow you to stay
oriented during the retroperiod approach
but some surgeons have become
disoriented because they're not exactly
sure where they are and that is
sometimes led to injury
there's also the risk of making a small
hole in the peritoneal cavity
from the retroperitoneal space and then
the carbon dioxide from the
retroperitoneum space will then enter
into the transparent
space and that can compress your already
small
retroperitoneal space and make
visibility and exposure more difficult
and there are some ways to work around
that
so for example with regard to the
working space when you fill up the
transparent space in an average adult
to 15 millimeters of mercury pressure
the amount of carbon dioxide
gas in there is about four and a half to
five liters for the same pressure in the
retroperitoneum space
you can see the space is much smaller
it's 1.5 to 2 liters so
this is a much smaller smaller space
which means if your assistant
is aggressively sucking in the
retroperion space they can deflate the
space very quickly
and it can compromise visibility
so how do we do how do we develop the
retroperitoneal space
well the first is to put the first step
is to put the patient in the correct
position so the patients are placed in a
true
flank position so that means 90 degrees
it's not a modified flank
they're fully upright and the idea here
is to flex the patient at the level of
the umbilicus with the bed as you can
see here
and to increase the space between the
hip and the twelfth rib and that allows
you enough space to get the robotic
ports in
so here's a picture of what it looks
like with the patient in the flank
position
we use what's called soft positioning
with tape and
and blankets and there's no bean bag
here there's nothing hard
and allows us to do this procedure in
patients who are very large without any
compromise to their to their pressure
points
one of the important points about the
flank position is that the shoulder and
hip must be aligned before you start to
flex them
this is a very important uh point in
order to create enough space
if the shoulder and the hip are not
aligned then when you when you bend the
the table they're not going to flex
fully and they're not going to open up
the space and they're just going to bend
either forward or bend backward
and you won't have the benefit of the
flexion
so the robot that we currently use is
the latest generation fourth generation
davinci
xi the benefits of the xi especially for
the retroperitoneal approach
are that the arms are actually a bit
smaller and you can put them closer
together and again
as i mentioned this is a small space so
ideally you would try
and get the arms as close together now
when you have a very small space if the
arms are
larger and there's a lot of collision
between the arms you can only get three
arms in but with the davinci xi
we now can do what's called a forearm
approach where we're actually using all
four robotic arms
so one arm would be for the camera and
then we'd have three operating arms
that we can manipulate during the
procedure
the other benefit of the davinci xi
robot is that you're not limited by
docking
you can dock the robot from any position
and that improves your access
so here's a picture of what the port
configuration looks like using the
davinci xi on the right side
so we have the camera in the mid
axillary line just above the iliac crest
the left robotic arm in this case would
be in the posterior axillary line
the right and the anterior axillary line
and the fourth arm in this case would be
in the mid clavicular line and you can
see there's a gentle arc to the ports
here and this allows the
arms to work very closely together
without collision
so using the forearm technique we're
able to get the arms almost
down to five centimeters in many cases
but we usually
try and get six centimeters between the
arms and then
the fifth port in this case is for the
assistant in the lower quadrant here
and the in the assistant is important
because this is how how you're
going to get suction you're going to
have your needles brought in the bulldog
clamps that you use all that's going to
be brought to the assistant porch this
is a 12 millimeter port
and you'd like to get some distance
between the robotic ports and the
assistant if the assistant is too close
to the robotic ports
then when the arms come down to do the
kidney work the assistant's not going to
be able to move
they're going to be handcuffed and
they're not going to be able to help you
so you need at least eight centimeters
to allow the system to be free and
mobile during the operation
and here's just demonstrating the gentle
arc now one of the changes we may
you can make sometimes to give your
assistant more room is to switch the
instruments between the fourth arm and
the
and the right arm in this case and the
reason for that is that the fourth
robotic arm
is actually a retracting arm in most
cases and this is used to hold the
kidney
up to retract it up and that gives you
improves your visibility
well when the kidney is is being held up
by the fourth arm inside the body on the
outside
the fourth arm is actually coming down
because the port acts
as a as a full a fulcrum point and
that pivot point makes the arm come down
when it comes down it can come down to
the assistant if that's the case
if you're in a case say for example on
an upper pole tumor and the fourth arm
is coming down on the assistant
you can alleviate that conflict by
switching
the fourth arm to the port next to the
camera and then placing your scissor
on the as the most anterior port how
does that change things well the fourth
arm now
if it's holding up is no longer going to
be down on the assistant it's going to
be down
closer to the hip and the right arm in
this case
would would be a scissor in most cases
if you're right-handed
and that would be pointing down towards
the highland towards the tumor
and it's not going to be on the
assistant so this is a a
adjustment can that can be made to give
your assistant more mobility
uh during a retroperitoneal approach
so creating the space involves placement
of a
dilating balloon which is commonly used
for hernia surgery
in the retroperitoneal space and it's
basically placed between the psoas
muscle
and the kidney and the kidney is pushed
anteriorly
this balloon allows a scope to be placed
so that you can actually see the
landmarks in the structures during
dilation
this is the balloon that i use it's a a
balloon
that's shaped more like a a a football
if you will
and this allows their a robotic port
all right in as well as camera so that
you can actually see
the landmarks through the balloon
there's another balloon made that's
kind of a more of a round balloon but
it's just doesn't create enough space so
we routinely don't use that balloon we
like the longer oblong balloon
and so the balloon is placed in that
first mid-axillary incision where the
camera is going to go
and this is a place just above the iliac
crest about a centimeter by the iliac
crest
so once we make our incision we actually
poke down through the oblique muscles
with a tonsil clamp and then just bring
our finger in there to
enter through the oblique muscles into
the retroperitoneal space
and we're just creating enough space
with our finger to get the balloon in
place
so now once we've created enough space
the balloon has an obturator which
allows you to
bring the balloon into the space so i'm
using the operator to kind of push the
balloon
in underneath the oblique muscles you
want to get underneath the oblique
muscles so it dilates
uh in the retroperitoneal space
and then for the davinci xi um the
eight millimeter camera uh actually will
not
um fit to this 10 millimeter balloon
port so we put the eight millimeter
uh robotic port into the balloon port
and that allows you to actually watch
the balloon inflate while you're it's
being inflated by
the air syringe that you see the
assistant uh
pumping up so here is the balloon
uh unfurling if you will inside the
retroperitoneus space and we see some
very important landmarks
this is the source muscle we're seeing
here and then this is the the edge of
deroda's fascia being pushed off the
cellus muscle posteriorly
and as we turn the scope up we see the
transversus abdominis muscles anteriorly
and the peritoneal reflection underneath
the fat here and so those are the
important landmarks that we want to see
with the balloon in place
once the balloon is removed we put our
first port in
and now this is actually an older video
where i would put an eight millimeter
porter and then just do a purse stringer
on it which works quite nicely
and that allows you to create a seal
here
uh and we're going to put co2 through
this port
to um create our space
so this is um what we did originally
with a balloon port using the 8mm report
i don't recommend this anymore
mainly because the remote center of your
port is out of the body and there's lots
of
um friction here moving your camera
around it's not an ideal situation so
i wouldn't recommend putting a balloon
port in
our sound balloon port and then the
robotic port through there
this is what we use now this is the
robotica sound port it's meant for the
eight millimeter port it's got a hassan
attachment
and you can adjust this and this works
quite nicely and it does not
um it'll it prevents the leaking
around the port that you see uh when you
put carbon dioxide in
so now that we have our camera port in
the next step is to put our second port
in which is
routinely the posterior port and this
goes underneath the 12th rib
in the posterior axillary line again
we're using a tonsil clamp to show
where the port is going to come through
and then
using the two hander technique here
gently put the eight millimeter robotic
port in
and we put this posterior port in first
because this is how we're going to gain
more access in the space we're going to
create more space here by putting a
blunt dissector through this port
and pushing the peritoneum off
anteriorly
so we have our camera through the mid
axillary port
we have the blood dissector the
posterior axillary
line port and we're going to use that to
push the peritoneum off so this is what
it looks like on the inside so there's
the peritoneum down below
that's the transverse abdominis muscle
above and all i'm doing is gently
pushing
the fat and the peritoneal way and all
and i'm gaining more space anteriorly
and as i gain more space this is going
to allow me to have enough room to put
two additional ports anteriorly
uh which will allow us to use the to
perform the form
the four on technique so here we are
putting in um our most anterior port
here and that's right next to the
peritoneal line
and routinely we're about 12 centimeters
from the camera port
between this most anterior port and the
camera port and you can see we've marked
our
our system port below the um
the most anterior port here so we have
our
our robotic port in there
we've already placed our other robotic
port in and now we're probably seeing
our system port this is a 12
millimeter air seal port
uh we really like air steel for the
retroperiton approach because
it allows you to maintain uh an
excellent new up here at the end even
though the space is quite small so this
is our
our system for the 12 millimeter air
seal
so docking for the retropieting approach
can be done from any direction this is
very important because routinely
you saw our assistant was anterior so
the majority of the time were either
docking over the foot or were docking
over the back
but you can dock from the front if you
need to you can dock from the foot or
you can dock from the back and
that's because the davinci xi is on a
boom so let's show you what that looks
like so this boom rotates
so here's the four robotic arms coming
into position
on the patient's back assistant's going
to be anteriorly here
and you can see the arms rotate and
we're actually putting the
laser x on our camera port that's our
orientation
and we'll rotate that a little bit just
to make sure that the line lines up with
the ports
we'll drop the arms as a unit and then
dock the robotic arms to the
to the ports and that's going to allow
us to put instruments in and out
so you can see we have plenty of space
between the arms
and um and that's
that's what docking looks like and then
once
we have things docked we have our camera
here this is a zero degree lens
we have a scissor in the right arm here
this is a fenestrated bipolar on the
left and then we have a progress as our
fourth robotic arm
uh retracting instrument and then our
assistant here with the 12 millimeter
system port
here's what it looks like on the other
side and here's what it looks like at
the end of the procedure
this is where we the camera was we
actually extend this incision in this
case to
remove our specimen and then close the
incisions
and we have our drain in the other port
there now one of the key steps in
creating enough space
is dealing with the fat that's in the
retroperitoneum and
i like to call this step fat management
it's not well described but it's a very
important part of the
procedure and that's because in the
retroperitoneum there's a layer of fat
that's outside your dispersion called
the
perinephric fat so the para nephric fat
which is different from the fat inside
derivative fashion which is the
peri network fat and removing this
parent effort fat outside your test
fascia is critical
for good good view and exposure so this
is just a diagram of what we're talking
about there is a fat layer that's
outside yours fashion that's very
important
and it's separate from the perinephric
fat surrounding the kidney we're not
going to remove the fat around the
kidney unless there's a lot of fat but
we routinely
remove this fat if it's if it's in our
way now in thin patients it's not always
in the way we don't have to do anything
about it
but here's just an example of what it
looks like so the white layer on the
other side of the scissor is derodus
fascia
and then this is the perinephric fat
that's outside of drodous fascia
it's in the space between the ribs if
you will
and jordan's fascia and we remove this
layer
and just throw in the lower
retroperitoneum and then remove that at
the end of the case
and and that is no longer hanging in our
face and now we have a very clear view
of toronto's fashion this is the
posterior derotator's fascia
and now we're entering that space to get
in the space where the kidney lives and
that's how we
begin our exposure of the kidney and you
can see gerotis fascia
can be opened up quite nicely and we
have excellent exposure
despite the fact it's a small space
so let me um begin by
presenting a case of a 75 year old
female
with a four centimeter left renal mast
found incidentally
during evaluation for breast cancer
surveillance so this patient had
previous breast cancer
and was undergoing imaging um
she has had a previous hysterectomy so
she's had some previous abdominal
surgery
uh and so that's one of the reasons we'd
like to do a retrograde new approach
um but you can see the tumor here is
actually posteriorly located but it's
actually
near the renal hilum probably more
importantly
let me just show you that one more time
you can see this tumor is located right
in next to the renal artery and the
renal vein
and um
so this is the renal vein
this is the renal artery you can see
it's right next to the tumor so this is
a very
challenging tumor location but the tumor
is located posteriorly if you will
so here's the left kidney here's the
spine here's the right kidney
here's the liver here's the pancreas
here's the spleen
but the tumor is so here's the aorta
so arteries coming off the aorta
and you can see the tumor above both the
artery and the vein
so this is a very challenging location
and so based on the location it's
posteriorly based
uh we felt the retroperitoneal approach
would be the best way to approach this
now this is a model we are now using a
3d model
from a company called civra which allows
us to get actually a better idea where
the tumor is in relation to the vessels
and the kidney
so you can see you can remove things you
can rotate the
these uh kidney and you can see
we see the tumor here and then we see
that the vein we just took away and
here's the artery see how close the
artery is
to the tumor itself as well as to the
ureter this is the ureter here
this is the what we call the collecting
system of the kidney where the urine is
collected
and then it drains down the ureter into
the bladder but you can see
the tumor is very close to the artery
and abuts the ureter as well so maybe we
should do that
model one more time
so the um tumor is
pretty much we call this a hilar tumor
when the tumor is in the center of the
kidney and
near the renal vessels uh these are
called higher tumors and they're
more complex than the usual tumor that's
out on the periphery of the kidney
surface
and they require more care and attention
to how the
tumor is relates to the vessels
so here's the tumor here i'm just going
to stop this for a second so here's the
kidney ear for orientation
we've already done a lot of the work
already of exposing
the kidney and the fat and
i'm just going to back up a little bit
here and
show you kind of where things are so
this is my right hand instrument a
scissor this is my left hand instrument
this is actually a retractor so this is
my fourth dimension so i'm going to use
this to hold the kidney up
this is the normal kidney here and this
is where the tumor
interfaces with the normal kidney now
i've already made a mark on the kidney
here with cautery this is
was done with ultrasound to actually
identify the tumor and this is what we
call our margin of resection so i've
used
ultrasound to make a score mark if you
will and the ultrasound tells me
where the how far the tumor extends into
the kidney and allows me to plan
a margin of resection that's going to
ensure that i remove the entire
tumor and not leave any tumor behind
so orientation is that this is the back
of the kidney
back of the left kidney tumor here
scissor
and this is my retracting instrument
here so we're just gonna um
oops we're gonna go back sorry about
that
so one of the
i'm sorry
so what we found during the operation is
there was an
artery that was going directly to the
tumor coming
off the main artery so this is the main
artery here this was going directly to
tumor so one of the techniques
to free up the tumor which is you have
to do
is you'd have to remove move remove the
connection between
the tumor and this artery so i'm using a
suture here
a silk suture these are needle drivers
so you can see my robotic instruments
have changed
i no longer have a scissor in my right
hand
and i have both hands now i have what
are called
needle drivers and these needle drivers
allow me to suture or tie knots
so i'm just using a tie here to tie this
vessel before i divide it so that we can
have excellent blood flow control to the
tumor
whoa did that again
so there's the vessel wow that's not
allowing me to do that
there's the vessel
there's dividing the vessel
now we're clamping the artery and now
we're dividing
the plane between the
kidney here and the tumor here so you
can see
we have we've clamped the artery so
we're cutting this with very good
visibility if we had not clamped the
kidney
we wouldn't be able to see very well and
there would be a lot of blood here but
now we have what we call
ischemia to the kidney and of course we
want to limit the ischemia time because
the longer the kidney is clamped the
less blood flow it's getting less oxygen
it's getting
and and and the longer the kidney is
clamped
the less well the kidney functions
afterwards now there are
there's a pretty wide range on how long
the kidney can be clamped before it
starts to suffer any injury
so we do have um a lot of time
but we always like to limit the time the
kidney is clamped because
all organs like oxygen so that's our
goal here is to try and limit the
ischemia so there's the excision and
there's a little branch here just
so you can see so there's a this is the
main artery this is where we remove the
tumor from the kidney
there's a little artery branch going to
the tumor itself which i'm just
cauterizing
with the scissors this black suture is
where i tied off the artery that was
going to the tumor before
there's the cautery and then there's the
tumor the final tumor connection to the
kidney
and then there here's the artery here
here's the vein and you can see we're
having to very carefully peel
the tumor off of the artery
just try to slow this down now the tumor
is is
completely freed almost there's a little
bit of fat connection
so now we place the tumor in a bag and
now we're suturing
the base of the defect where the tumor
was
so this is a raw surface here where the
tumor is located
and we're using suture to suture any
vessels that might be
exposed here so they don't bleed when we
take the clamps off
right if you notice right here in the
bottom there's actually a clamp
that's the clamp that's on the artery
this white uh
structure here is actually a clip it's a
it's made of a polymer material
and this clip is being placed on the
suture as a way to secure the suture
so instead of having to tie another knot
this suture will actually hold
this clip will hold the suture and keep
the suture from slipping so this is a
technique that
is used commonly during robotic partial
nephrectomy
to actually speed up the closing process
and decrease the time the kidney is
clamped
now on the outside of these white clamps
are these little purple clamps
these are called lapra tie clips these
actually secure the suture even tighter
than the
the white polymer clips and so these are
used to reinforce these clips
and allow the clips not to slide
at all so they're very secure
so you can see we're taking the slack
out of the sutures
and you can see our defect is
coming together quite nicely
so that was the removal and the of the
tumor and the closure um
so let me show you another case this is
a patient
um who was noted to have a cyst
so a cyst is a basically a fluid-filled
mass on the kidney
it's not solid like the tumor we just
saw this is a fluid-filled mass
and was initially diagnosed in 2012 and
it was followed
bosniak is a grading system for cysts
and a bosniak two cyst is actually
not something we usually operate on but
the cyst
was followed over time and appeared to
increase within complexity
and ultrasound showed the cyst actually
had increased in complexity and so a ct
scan was performed
so here's the ct scan showing the tumor
here and the tumor does not look like a
simple cyst it actually has
this white rim within the cyst we call
that enhancement
so this is the normal kidney on the
right side this is the normal kidney on
the left
here's the normal kidney tissue hem here
which is white
and then during the cyst itself there is
a room of enhancement so that gives us
concern
that this may not just be a simple cyst
it actually may represent
a cancer so these are the kind of cysts
that we have to remove
and here's the same view of the cyst you
can see it's kind of lobular
it's got areas that would actually
appear to be solid here
not just cystic you can see there's a
little nodule right here
and so this is on the upper pole of the
left kidney
on the back so this turns out to be a
bosniac forces because of the solid
component
and the patient had a prior left collect
me for diverticulitis so
this is one of those patients i
described to you that had a previous
abdominal surgery we can anticipate a
lot of scarring and adhesion
and this is something that would make a
transparent needle procedure quite
difficult
retroperitoneally we can avoid all that
so that would be our
our approach of choice in this
particular case
so here we are you can see a little more
fat in this case
patients a little more fat and so we've
done the exposing here this is the
ultrasound i described you and this is
the solid tumor right here
so let me show you right here i just
stop it here this is the cyst here it's
it's darker you can see it's
it's fluid filled and this brighter mass
here
is a solid component of this cyst this
is the normal kidney tissue here
so the ultrasound is being controlled by
the robotic instrument so we've
we brought the instrument the robotic
the ultrasound through the body
uh into a through the port being
controlled by robotic
uh instruments that allow me to move the
ultrasound across the kidney to look at
the
depth of the tumor and the relationship
between the tumor and the rest of the
kidney
so this is a very important tool during
partial nephrectomy
to give me information about the full
extent of the kidney
full extent of the tumor and the
relationship between the two
so now we're we're marking our margin as
i showed you before
these are the bulldog clamps i described
previously now in this case
i should back up a tiny bit here just
for the sake of completeness
so in this case there's actually two
arteries this is the main renal artery
but this patient had an upper pole
accessory artery and this
this occurs about 15 to 20 percent of
time there'll be a second
artery going to the kidney these clamps
are
being placed on the artery as a way to
stop the blood flow the kidney
temporarily we can take these if we can
put these on and take these off now we
only want to do that once during the
operation
but they're very easy to put on and take
off and by temporarily occluding
the kidney we have excellent control of
the blood flow and allows us to remove
the tumor
and see when we do that as well as see
when we do the closure of the kidney
you can see the bulldog clamps come in
different sizes this is a medium clamp
here
going across the larger artery this is a
small clamp here
which is actually going to go across
this upper pole artery which is smaller
so we want to control the entire blood
flow to the kidney
so there's a smaller bulldog clamp
there's the artery now
you can see the screen has turned green
let me back up a little bit so what
what's going on there
so there is a substance we can
put intravenously during the operation
called
endocyan in green endocyting green is
carried in the blood system
and then it will show you what is
getting perfusion and what is not
getting perfusion
we put this dye into the
into the vessels into the veins during
the operation as a test
to confirm that we have no blood flow
to the kidney before we cut out the
tumor as you saw we had an accessory
artery
what if we had not seen that artery and
we had just clamped the main artery and
we started to cut the tumor out
what we would have had was a lot of
bleeding
we don't want a lot of bleeding because
it inhibits our visibility and it
doesn't allow us to see our margin of
removal
so we want to confirm that we have
complete blood control blood flow
control to the kidney
and so that's what this green dye does
so we've given the green dye
we look at the kidney if we don't see
any green
on the kidney that means there's no
blood flow and that confirms that we
have complete ischemia
and that's what we want before we remove
the tumor
so we don't see any the kidney looks
basically
non-green we've confirmed our ischemia
and now we're cutting the tumor out
here's our scissors in the right hand we
have a bipolishment in the left hand you
can see
we're using our margin of resection that
we previously scored and now we're
getting deeper and deeper in the kidney
we're in the area of the kidney that
collects the urine we call it the
collecting system
and within the center of the kidney
itself there's actually fat there's fat
on the outside there's fat
on the inside now we always put a
specimen in the bag to remove it and we
do that in this case during the
operation
so that allows us to
have that under control we're now
suturing the base of the defect where
the blood vessels
and the urine collect and we're using
two different types of suture here one
is a
braided suture called bicycle the other
is a monofilament suture
and this monofilament suture allows us
to close all the vessels
in the center of the kidney and we bring
it on the outside and there you see
those white clips again
that are securing the suture without
having to tie them
we then so that's our deep layer so now
we're going to do a second layer on the
outside so we did a deep layer and now
we're closing the outside of the kidney
again using
the braided suture in this case with the
clips and you can see that brings the
edges together
and by bringing the edges together that
compresses the kidney and keeps it from
bleeding when we take the clamps off
there's the purple leopard tie clips
again securing our hemolog
clips and there's our completed closure
so the warmest scheme time for that
procedure was 19 minutes which is
below our 30 minute target so our target
for one more scheme time is 30 minutes
in many cases we're under 20 minutes
this
the analysis of this tumor it turned out
indeed to be a kidney cancer is a cystic
renal cell carcinoma four centimeters
the firming grade
is the uh how the cells appear under the
microscope with regard to how aggressive
they appear
it was a three out of four with regard
to the grade
and the margin which is the border that
i removed was clear of tumor so the
margin was negative
the patient did very well went home the
day following surgery again as i
mentioned
uh when we don't manipulate the
intestines we work in the
retroperitoneum
uh patients tend to eat faster and have
a faster
time out of the hospital now one of the
questions that's always asked is when
you take out
the tumor and some of the normal kidney
how much kidney function
do you impact by doing this so there's a
a study called
renogram it's a nuclear medicine study
and we actually do this study on all of
our patients prior to surgery
and then we do it on our patients three
months after surgery and we compare the
two numbers
and then the difference in the pre and
post
number is the amount of function we
affected by removing the tumor
so the pre-operative renogram for the
left kidney in this patient was 48
now interestingly most renograms show
that each kidney could change about 50
to the overall kidney function each
kidney tends to do about half the
overall kidney work
and so this is very close to 50 at 48
percent
three months later the arena grams
showed it was 44
so we only lost four percent function by
removing that entire
large four centimeter tumor which i
think is a testament to how we do the
operation how the robot allows us to do
this procedure very precisely
allows us to do the suturing very
precisely so we have
a very good kidney which this patient
could
you know live with for example if
something were to happen
to the other kidney say another tumor or
an injury
this patient should be able to live with
this this left kidney for the rest of
their lives
so this is another reason we do partial
refrectomy it gives the patient
you know the option if a tumor comes
back and these tumors can come back
renal cell carcinoma can
come back in the other kidney so if we
have the opportunity
to remove just the tumor and spare the
kidney that's a benefit for the patient
going forward
so with that i'd like to thank you for
your attention
i really enjoyed explaining to you
how we're doing robotic partial
nephrectomy
uh using the retroperitoneal approach
if you have any questions about the talk
feel free to email me at porter swedish
urology.com that's porter
swedishurology.com
thank you so much really appreciate your
attention
and hope you enjoy the rest of the
conference
take care